[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar targeted high throughput snip
and haplotype genotyping with flex seek
excel i am marie stone of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by lgc biosearch technologies to
learn more visit biosearchtech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions for
our speaker we encourage you to
participate in poll questions dispersed
throughout the presentation
to record your answer to the poll
questions when they are displayed click
on the answer that is most accurate for
you
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
leandro nevis lgc biosearch technologies
dr nevis you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you good morning good
afternoon good night everyone i know we
have people from all over the world here
so i'm very thankful to be uh presenting
to you today
and
as we just talked if you have any
questions during the presentation feel
free to type those and we'll be asked
answering those questions at the end and
today we're going to be talking a lot
about some of the methods that we've
been developing how we've been applying
that to you to
the different systems and the different
questions that i've been
faced over the last
decade or so
i'm the senior director of research and
innovation for lgc genomics
in in i we want to make this
presentation a little bit more
interactive so i will be asking a few
questions throughout the presentation
would be great if you could participate
i'll give a few seconds for everybody to
go click on them
and then we'll see the results together
and so please help me answer some of
those questions
and again thank you for for joining me
today so let's get it started i'll get
started with one question
uh so what organism or systems do you
work with
please choose your options there based
on plants animals microbes aquaculture
in in or orders if you don't have
any of those systems there i'll give
about five to ten seconds for everybody
to
uh to answer here and then we'll go to
the presentation itself yeah
no pressure just if you if you feel like
you can participate they'll be great so
we can
run the numbers here
all right let's see where we are yeah
with the results uh
all right we have a lot of plant uh
plants uh folks here you know about 20
folks working animals let me let me
refresh
see how that changes
yeah
and i can
we had only 10 participants so far
a few more people participating now i'll
give a couple more seconds
all right here's where we are so far and
let me see if i can push this result to
you
and you might be able to see that result
now a few more few more people have
clicked since but it sounds like we have
a good split here between plant and
animals and also microbes having a good
percentage of of the group as well so
great thanks for participating
and i'll be i'll be touching on these
different systems during the
presentation so that helps me a lot to
see what areas perhaps i need to focus a
little bit more
so as an overview of the today's
presentation you know we'll be
talking about the capabilities and
products that we that we have that are
available to you
i'll be talking a little bit about how
we are overcoming some of the challenges
that we see in the complex genomes that
we work with that being plants animals
or any other systems right
we'll be talking about the flexique
excel techno technology and how that can
be used and i'll show a few specific
examples so i'm going to show a
different density of genotyping that we
can use
i'm also going to show our industry
standard series which are panels are
available for you off the shelf
and we'll talk a little bit about a
haplotyping how we can go beyond just
snip genotyping and and try to get more
information from this data rich
genotyping platform
so a little bit about
us myself i'm from brazil i grew up in
brazil if you have picked up the accent
i moved to florida
here in the united states the city is
called gainesville and together with two
other co-founders we we actually founded
rapid genomics which is a company
that's been established in 2011. and the
goal
both for my career as a researcher and
then as as a founder of rapid genomics
has always been to simplify genomics you
know i've always found that genomics had
to be simplified so we can approach you
know broaden that application to so many
more questions and i have a big interest
on on genetics
and in large scale adoption of that
genetics that being towards breeding
quantitative genetics or population
genetics so that's kind of like where
our mindset was
as we're developing a lot of the
technologies and we very much are
research driven and commercially focused
so we have unique products and solutions
for for our customers and we really want
to have that scientific expertise to
understand your questions understand
your needs
and we're very much focused on that
really trying to provide you with
solutions that you can then take this
and and
and answer a lot of interesting uh
questions your to your program or your
research
in just this month i'm happy to announce
the rapid genomics joints lgc group and
so we're now part of the family and
that's why we're going to be making this
webinar today to show some of the
capabilities and how we can bring this
to you
to the existing and new customers for
for lgc
uh all right so a little bit of the
overview of the capabilities you know
during during the last decade with
genotype hundreds of species and in a in
a range of projects now the core
competency of the company and the team
is in agrigenomics so we understand uh
very well you know the challenges that
that you were facing as as an adopter of
this technology
and and most importantly we we try to
bring this technology to an industrial
breeding application it's a very large
scale
application because you know we know
breeding in some of the other
quantitative genetics population
genetics those are
data-driven and very large numbers to be
able to come up with the answers so we
try to see that from the beginning of
the process
our methods are uh you know we stand by
these principles we try to be very
focused on what we're doing what we're
trying to achieve
the quality has to be good so it has to
be an accurate and reproducible data set
we we try to build a lot of flexibility
into our products
and lastly they need to be fast as fast
as technology allows
and so
so our lab
is located in florida in the united
states so we have a high throughput
laboratory here i'm putting a few
pictures of of the laboratory so so you
can see what it looks like a lot of
automation a lot of liquid handlers
and systems to to type things together
but it relies a lot on the team and the
people and we really value it and try to
encourage a good synergy and
explain to everybody what the goals of
the projects are so people feel
connected with the customer during this
journey even the folks on our lab as
well and and i'm happy to announce that
as part of lgc we will be expanding some
of our capabilities to other sites as
well so stay tuned and we're hopefully
going to be reaching closer to your
demographics there if you're not located
in the southeast the united states but
we do receive samples from all over the
world and we can also provide a support
to clients worldwide
and
so another thing that we pride ourselves
is that we try to have a lot of
transparency of how we're doing
how we're doing business how our methods
are are working and we have a laboratory
information management system and there
is a customer portal there is available
to you once you start projects with us
that allows you to track the samples in
real time and you can see those updates
as we're progressing so i'm showing here
two snapshots of that
of that customer portal where you can
see at a glance where the project is or
you can also see the details on the
right side of every single plate that
you submit you can see how far you are
in the process and you can really
download some information and interact
with the system a little bit because our
goal is to give you that transparency as
far as where we are with the process and
we we also created a a mobile app for
both android and ios
that you can download and see that those
updates in real time
so so that's the in a nutshell about a
rapid genomics now joining lgc
and when we think about the capabilities
of this of the team and sort of like
this you know market assisted
breeding pipeline as i like to think
about it
we we start with the whole genome
sequencing many times many times we want
to understand the diversity of the
entire population
and this can be done either at a lower
depth or a higher sequence in depth
so we can have different levels of
accuracy on the data and requirements of
imputation or or things like that but as
we progress
you know and if i if we think about it
we also have the capture seek which is a
targeted genotyping method that allows
us to target anywhere from let's say a
thousand to four hundred thousand loci
and if we go another another stage
deeper and that's the topic of today's
webinar we're gonna be focusing mostly
on the on the flex seek excel
and that flex c technology allows us to
go anywhere from one to let's say 45 000
loci and these are sort of rough numbers
right
and then lastly as part of the lgc team
we also have access to the caps
technology that is a pcr based a system
that allows you to do very large number
of samples from one to let's say 192
loci
so if we if we think about you know
when do you need each one of those
technologies and obviously that's
something that it's very fluid but at a
glance i usually think that these
technologies here on the bottom bottom
of the pyramid they're mostly used for
allele discovery so you're going to be
using this for pre-breeding marker
discovery germaplex characterization
this can be used for especially the
capture seek
can be used for research insertion site
characterization so if you have a a
genetic event or if you have a
transgenic event and you want to know
where in the genome that got
incorporated and also on a research
level if you're trying to understand new
new your traits understanding that
genomic architecture so we can do also
genome-wide association studies
and and as the breeding progresses as
you're doing more samples that we we
we tend to think that the next step is
going to be on the industrial genotyping
process either with flexique or casp and
that's a very high throughput genotyping
used for genomic prediction you know
markers is a selection uh parentage
identification and applications like
that and and those are available to you
as either a service or as a kit
depending on your on your needs and as
you can imagine the number of samples is
moving
through this pyramid and on an inverted
basis typically so typically you start
with last samples on the whole genome
sequencing or capture c and when it gets
to the to the flex seek and the cast
you're actually doing uh
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
samples
yeah
so
what what sets us apart here i think is
that we are embracing the common
challenge that we see in these genomes
or genotyping instead of being reactive
to some of those challenges we're
actually
embracing them when we're developing
technologies so i put here four
different challenges that we usually
encounter so so you know this is no
stranger to you
you know that we have
as a community we have very repetitive
dna and large genomes
uh a lot of those genomes are highly uh
diverse in heterozygous so you can have
you know nucleotide diversities uh
if they're one snip every you know 20
bases 100 bases so you have a lot of
diversity and a lot of times you have
heterozygosity
and
this has been changing over the years
but we still face ourselves with a lot
of incomplete or unavailable references
for those species and systems that we're
working on
and you know the favorite of everybody
and we also have a lot of polyploidy a
lot of the important species especially
on the plant side are polyploids and
that's what sets them apart so instead
of like being reactive to so to those
challenges when we are developing
technologies
at lgc
we're thinking how can we embrace those
and how can we plan ahead so our
technologies are are tolerant to those
challenges and in fact they can overcome
and allow us to embrace some of those
challenges
so i'm going to put some of the
solutions here so for example you know
if because the repetitive dna is present
in large genomes we develop a lot of
targeted genotyping technology so you
can focus your your sequencing and your
your genotyping on the regions that are
important to you and exclude some of
that large repetitive dna
these are also you know
very effective probe design as i'm going
to show and the chemistry is very
effective to tolerate those diversities
so you don't need to compensate for
snips around your target snip side we
understand that there's going to be
diversity and we actually build systems
to tolerate that diversity on a
polyploid level you also need efficient
chemistry and you need you know you can
benefit from haplotyping and we'll talk
a little bit about that in a few minutes
and then lastly
because you have a lot of incompleteness
of unknowns on the system it is very
important that you have a flexible
genotyping approach that compensates for
those challenges and i hope that you're
going to see as we're going through the
presentations how each one of those
areas was very very well thought out so
we could address them as we're
developing the technology and the
projects instead of reacting to them
later on as a lot of other
folks can do
so so before we we dive deep into the
technology let's just say set aside a
little bit of time here to think about
what is a genotyping versus a haplotype
genotyping so typically if you have a
target which i'm showing here in orange
on a genome which is this black line and
let's say you have a particular snip so
if you sequence this with 10 reads
you're going to see if it's a
heterozygous individual you're going to
see some reads supporting the the allele
some reads supporting the g allele but
what does that mean
specifically if you have a certain
population i'm showing here two examples
one in poultry and one in blueberry
that means that if you have a single
snip
you can separate the population up to
three
groups so that can be the
aaa
individuals who have the aa allele that
some individuals are going to have the
ag heterozygous allele and some
individuals are going to be homozygous
for for the g
allele so that's it you can only
separate the population for this biolic
marker in three groups
instead if you're working on a haplotype
and let's say you you you have a
adjacent snip on the target region you
can actually start to phase these
alleles so for example you know that
every time you see the a allele on one
locus you're gonna see the g allele on
the other locus and every time you see
the g allele on the first locus you're
gonna see the t allele on the second
locus so you can use the sequencing data
and that's an advantage of using
acceleration sequencing is that we can
actually build multi-allylic markers
just like we used to do with
microsterolites and some of those other
multi-allylic data and the advantage
here is that now
if you have those same two populations
for the same locus that you're
sequencing you can now break this
population into a larger number so you
can separate your population further so
we can have
in this case i'm showing four alleles
but oftentimes we see five six seven
alleles so now with the same
genotyping you have a better
separation of those of those individuals
and you can understand the genetics and
the underlying
variability better when you use
multi-allylic markers
through haplotyping we'll talk a little
about that that on the examples
so
now i want to dive deeper a little bit
into the flexi excel technology and
that's the product that we're offering
and we're going to be disc discussing a
little bit more today so for those of
you who are molecular biologists and and
enjoy a little bit more the the you know
the intricacies of the method i put this
light here to to show you so on step one
we're going to design uh probes that are
specific to the regions that we're
targeting and we're going to hybridize
those probes to the dna and we're
actually going to some of the uniqueness
here is that we're going to hybridize
them to both strands of the dna so we're
capturing
both sides of the dna and that adds a
lot of
it becomes a more robust system than
than if you're doing otherwise and then
we're going to complement the region in
between the probes
and that's what i'm showing on the lower
end of this item one there you can see
that the capture molecules that you
actually want to sequence
so in step and we're going more detail
on that reaction but on step two
we're going to index those
molecules through pcr
so we can actually know
what sample
the data has to be allocated to once we
we sequence that that library and then
we're actually on step three we're going
to sequence those libraries and four
we're going to utilize that for
different applications so that's in a
nutshell how the flexic reaction works
and
the main the main advantages that that
technology provides is that first it's a
very simple process so it's designed for
ultra high throughput genotyping it's
designed for routine applications
it is sequencing based like we're
discussing before so that allows for
haplotyping and some other
key key characteristics and it takes
just a few enzymatic steps and it's what
i call one plate uh reaction so that
means that you start with a plate of dna
and you keep adding uh reagents to that
plate and the buffers and the enzymes
are compatible so you don't have to be
changing
plates and doing cleanups and things
like that as you're processing through
that in your lab or if you know
we're doing that
as a service for you so that's the first
major advantage and the second advantage
that is a targeted genotyping so you
you're going to be concentrating the
sequencing resources and the goals where
it matters to you so you it also works
with legacy data so if you already have
some
regions of the dna that you're
genotyping or certain constraints that
you're working on
we can incorporate those on the design
as another in you know hence the name
flexi it's a very flexible genotyping so
it's suitable for diverse a very diverse
term plasma and goes like we don't need
to be concerned about whether there is
nips near snip side
we developed the technology thinking
that there was going to be diversity and
in fact that's what we're interested so
the technology is very flexible to that
degree you can adjust the panel over
time so if you're if on your research
you find new snips or new regions of
interest we can incorporate those on the
on the genotyping
and
we understand that you have different
goals and your projects have different
goals so instead of having a one size
fits all
you can adjust the marker density
to the different goals that you have so
if you need more markers less markers
and that's something that you can you
can do with with the flexi technology
and then lastly this is a probe
hybridization based process so it's not
a multiplex pcr and that brings a lot of
benefits and advantages to to the data
so most importantly you have a very
accurate and uniform data set because
when you think about it going through
let's say 30 cycles of pcr or 20 cycles
of pcr whatever it is
every cycle there's going to be a chance
for those primers to go in the wrong
place of the genome or to interact with
themselves to create noise and that
noise gets multiplied exponentially well
geometrically
over the the next cycles versus the
hybridization you're doing one
hybridization you're capturing those
molecules
and that's it that's the that's the
region that you're your target so the
data is going to be more uniform it's
going to tolerate more diversity in the
target regions and it's highly specific
with very high on target data so that's
like the major advantages but how how
exactly do you utilize flexi
so it's simple as one two three so the
first thing that we're going to work
with you to design the panels we're
going to plan what your goals are
there's going to be a bioinformatics to
understand
what regions of the genome we're going
to be targeting so that's the first step
is to really design the panel
and plan that with you and then the
second step we're going to validate that
panel so we're going to receive a few
samples from you or we might use some
some standard dna that we have here and
we're going to show you the match we're
going to show you here's how many
regions we're able to target
here's how the data looks like we can
optimize the pipeline for your needs if
needed and we're going to finalize that
design and then the third and last step
is now that we have a final panel we can
actually start using recurrent
genotyping for your needs so it starts
with some planning some validation and
then the freewheel effect of just really
genotyping those samples for you
or you doing that in-house and i want to
pause a little bit now and give a few
seconds for for us to ask
answer this question so what volume of
samples are you interested in genotyping
annually when you think about it you
know we're interested in doing perhaps
up to a thousand samples you know from a
thousand to
ten thousand more than ten thousand or
you're now in the planning phase and
you're not sure about what you're going
to be
genotyping soon so it would be great if
you could answer those questions so we
can shape the presentation here
and so i'll give a few seconds for for
everybody to
answer that question
all right hope everybody's having a good
time there
enjoying the day
let me let me see how many people
participated
all right we're having some uh
quite a few people answering here i'll
give a few more
few more seconds
yeah
and like there are some people now in
the planning phase and really thinking
about how to develop this
pipeline
so yeah thanks for participating there
there are a few more uh folks answering
now but i'm i'm just gonna i think we're
converging to you to the average here
so i'm just gonna
push the results for you
and so you can see that we have you know
a good a good mix here we have some
people working on on on you know pretty
large projects and a few folks starting
new new projects here so thanks thanks
for participating
uh so the next i want to go into some
some examples and some data that we've
generated over the years
that i think are good summaries for for
what we can do with this technology in
in exemplifies that in more details
so so first i want to focus a little bit
on the lower density side of the
equation so let's say you know by lower
density i mean
maybe up to 5 000 regions of the dna
and i i put together here three
different panels so one panel has a
thousand markers and one panel has three
thousand markers and one panel has five
thousand markers and these are
commercial panels that we're actually
utilizing for clients
at rapid genomics and throughout and
yeah the idea here is that we want to
see how uniform this data is so for
example this is a thousand panel it's
actually a soy
piano the 3000 piano is a porsche
panel that we developed and the 5 000
piano is a cattle
panel that we developed
so what we usually look is is this the
plot that we call the you know the the
uniformity plot so on the x-axis you
have the number of markers so each one
of those markers that we're that we're
targeting the locus
individually there so for the first one
we have near a thousand for the second
one we have three thousand and for the
for the four uh third one we have a
nearly and five thousand locus there and
on the y-axis we have the the how much
data was allocated to each one of those
loci
in an ideal world you want this to be a
very flat distribution so every
snip
receives the same amount of data and
that's what we call by uniformity and
this matters because that makes the data
easier to analyze it makes the project
easier to sequence and makes it more
more scalable and cost effective as well
so you can see that all these three
panels are pretty flat very horizontal
and and i put three samples there just
so you can see the variability between
samples and it's it's very tight at the
distribution between samples
the other panel the other kind of
metrics that we look on those panels
in addition to the uniformity which i'm
showing on the on the uh as a light teal
color
we also want to know how many markers
were recovered which i'm showing as a
darker teal
on the middle bar plots there and then
lastly we look at okay what is the data
usage out of what i sequence how much of
the data actually gets allocated to the
target
and you can see that for all those
panels again these are commercial panels
they do have some variation between them
based on the on the challenge of the
genome and the targets that we're going
after but you can see that we're always
above 90 percent on all those metrics
and
very importantly i want to highlight the
the market recovery so if we are
designing markers for a thousand or two
thousand five thousand ten thousand low
low side we're actually recovering the
vast majority of them
and lastly uh the data usage which is
okay out of the sequencing data that you
generate and how much of that data
actually goes towards the targets and we
get 95 to 99 of the data being on target
and that's a very high number uh for
those of you who are actually familiar
with sequencing and the allocation of
data you want that to be high
so in summary you know what i wanted to
show for these three panels and again in
soy power sign and cattle is that we
have a very high uniform data and over
you know i didn't show the data here but
we usually see over 97 agreement with
other genotyping approaches that could
be you know whole genome sequencing
microarray
chips and things like that
and then we we also see a very you know
nearly identical 99 agreement on a
sample to sample when we run repetitions
of the same sample so the repeatability
of this of these nip calls are very high
and and we have an excellent on target
rate
so i want to shift gears a little bit
now and say okay i showed you some of
the panels that we have and we've been
building this uh over time we've been
building this series that we call
industry standard series and where we're
taking a a particular species and we're
developing what i think is a good panel
for the community
and the first one that you know that i
want to show to you guys is is to help
the maze breeders out there and so we
built this this family mace
and the idea was to come up with a a
panel that's targeting 17 000 regions on
the genome so we have 17 000 loci but as
i mentioned to you before this is a
sequencing based technology so we're
actually
in maze is a very diverse
species so ultimately we're actually
genotyping
close to 30 000 snips
on those 17 000 loci and that allows us
to to develop haplotypes
if that's the goal so it's a haplotyping
compatible data set
and it contains industry proven markers
you know these are markers that we
identified and we know the community to
that has used
over over the years and we know they're
very efficient for for this
species in the case of mace
uh you know you might say i don't need
seventeen thousand you know i can get
away with less and that's where the
flexibility comes you can come to us and
say okay out of those seventeen thousand
i actually only need five thousand ten
thousand so that's something that you
can draw from these seventeen thousand
uh and and and the idea here i wanna
show you uh how this this data set
behaves so we sequenced a a range of
individuals already
in this with this panel
and and the first plot that i'm showing
here on the left on the top left is the
gap size between markers because we
wanted these markers to be evenly
distributed evenly distributed
throughout the genome so you can see
that over the chromosomes they are very
evenly distributed with a gap size of
about you know 100 to 120 000
base pair between between loci
and but most importantly this is also
very efficient panel so you can see
there's nearly a flat line on the
distribution that i showed you before
again the markers being the the
or the low side
being on the x-axis and the y-axis being
how much data gets allocated to each one
of those
loci so it's a very efficient
marker set that we've been building for
mace and it shows you what we're doing
for on this industry standard series we
want to create a higher density and
marker panel that you can select from uh
given your your goals and needs
okay
so we'll ship gears a little bit now and
we're going to go
beyond snip genotyping and we're going
to be looking at a haplotype genotyping
and haplotype genotyping is mostly
useful when you have enough diversity in
that short region that we're sequencing
it with the with the technology with the
flaxseed technology and i'm going to
show you the example that we've been
that we put together for blueberry so in
the case in case some of you are not
familiar with it and blueberries is a is
a fruit is a is a shrub that grows
in many countries on the northern
hemisphere
uh us europe and uh and it is
it is a very variable
plant species so we it's actually uh
there are several species that that
comprise what we call a blueberry
variety
the reference genome that that's
available in the literature which is for
the northern high bush it is a
tetraploid and that's what i'm showing
here on the top
of this of this spreadsheet and that's
so that's a tetraploid and and we also
we genotype a lot of samples to make
this project so we have some by parental
parents some progenies because we wanted
to trace some mendelian
segregation
we have the southern high bush cultivar
that's a
48 samples of them that grow here in the
salt
in the south united states
and then we also sequence some
native uh
species so you can see here that they
they there you know there's a vaccine a
arboretum and there is a
elioti and and so on
and they have different employees some
of them are diploid some of them are
hexaploid and some of them are
tetraploid so blueberries are very
complex system and you know similar to
what you see in in sugar cane
in other species there are there are
complex uh on their employee and in
specific hybridization as well
so so what we did is we
we selected targets the map to all four
homeologues of the reference genome in
the tetraploid plant and we designed
about 6
300
flexi targets
and we sequenced a haplotypes that were
on average about 400 base pairs for each
one of those 6 300 loci
and then we started to analyze the data
a bit so so what we what we've done here
i'm going to show some some schematics
and i'm showing what this let's say
target 1 out of 6 300 looks like
so you i'm putting here four lines
representing
each homologue of these
of this tetraploid plant and and you can
see that you know sometimes there is a
diversity and sometimes there is not
diversity between those those homologs
so in in an ideal world we're actually
going to be sequencing several samples
so for example when you look at sample
one you can build the haplotype based on
that diversity that exists between the
homologs for each one of those species
for each one of those samples so i'm
showing here four uh different
haplotypes built for for this sample one
and let's say you have another sample
two where you also can build some some
haplotypes so what we're trying to
achieve here is the situation where
we're asking okay what is the variation
that exists uh within
the the homolog between samples so for
example for the homolog 1a these two
samples are identical there are no
differences between them
for the homeology we start to see some
differences between the samples so there
is a homolog
specific snip between the the samples
and and so on and so forth and the
question that we're asking here is okay
what is the difference now between
homologs so you can see in this example
that the difference between
homolog 1a and 1b is four nucleotides
and the difference between homolog 1b
and 1c is 3
nucleotides and so on and so forth and
the idea here is that the variation
between homologs is higher than the
variation within homologs and that
allows you to build those haplotypes and
separate the plants
and in the different hablotypes on those
plants so to to test this data we we
drew a set of hypotheses so for example
you know there are some validations here
and we if this is
for sequencing a tetraploid a plant we
want to see the reeds mapping uniquely
to each homeowner that's the the
assumption number one
and assumption number two is that we're
going to see an equal distribution of
the reads for each homolog so let's say
if you sequence 100 x
as a sequence in depth
you would like to see 25 going to
homologue 1 25 going to homologue 2 25
to 3 and 25 to 4. so you you're sampling
all the four alleles of that tetraploid
plant
you do not want to see a
polymorphism within the homologue
because because you're separating them
well but you want to be able to separate
those homologs between species so this
gets more and more complex right because
you know polyploids are
are typically very complex
but i want to show you some data
i'm not going to go through every one of
those assumptions in in the interest of
time
but i will show you a few of those just
so you see and you can get a feel for
the data that you get out of this system
so the first one is is this a validation
assumption number two which is okay do i
see an equal distribution of reads per
homeology on a tetraploid plant so again
i took one plant is a tetraploid plant
and then i have here only 10 targets but
remember we have 6
300. so i just took the first 10 random
there's just no no that's just the top
10 of the of the matrix
and you can see how the data gets
allocated to each home alarm
it's it's obviously not perfect there is
a normal distribution around that but
you can see that on average you're
converting to a 25 25 25 25 so you have
enough data to get markers for each one
of those homologs and that's that's what
i'm showing here is and overall now is
the data for all 6
300
loci
and you can see how the distribution of
those percentages is
for each one of those the data location
per homolog
for each one of those homologs and on
average we converge to a 25 for each
homolog so that means back to that topic
about the probes in robust that the
design of the probes being very
important to tolerate diversity we're be
we're being able to design probes
they're able to find
specifically each one of those homologs
at the same rate so you don't see a lot
of homolog bias
you know which is what a lot of times
people refer as a certain ascertaining
bias on the data
and then the the next
and last
data that i want to show you is this
validation assumption that okay can we
tell homo logs from this different
species apart so i'm showing here the
example of this a
fuscatin
species of blueberry which it is a
diploid species and when we're looking
at the therapy do we tell
the two
chromosomes that you
the two homologous chromosomes apart on
this deployed a species
and and you can i'm showing here what
many of you might be familiar with is
the igv
viewer plot and there are two tracks on
this on this graph on the top one is is
actually the reference genome uh so it's
one of the one of the homologues and the
bottom one is the other homologue that
comes from the fuscatum
species
and every time you see a gray it means
that there is no difference on that
400 base region that we're sequencing
but every time you see some colors on
the on the vertical that means a
polymorphism and interestingly enough
what you want to see is a fixed allele
on one of the tracks
and that's what we're seeing we're
seeing this snips they're they're if
present and we can tell that these snips
are species specific they're coming from
that particular homolog and you can even
see some in dells there for those of you
who are familiar with igv plot
so so obviously we need to look at this
a genome-wide
but i wanted to show one example on a
visual level so you can see what kind of
power you get when you're looking at a
haplotype data
so so in summary and i want to leave
some time for questions and so so in
summary here i hope to show you that
we we have very tailored
genomic solutions for every stage of
your brain and research question and
we're happy to accommodate your needs if
we don't have something ready yet
and we we also have very flexible uh
products that are adaptable to any
species they're very accurate and
efficient
and we try to make this
as
scalable as we can which is my my next
point which is you know we need to build
something that is broadly adopted for
the community that's simple that can
scale and we can do thousands and
thousands of samples so the law a large
number
can help us there
and then and then lastly you know we
very much focus on adding value to
partners like yourselves and so i look
forward to working with with you on
different projects and i do have one
final question uh that we can we can do
as a team here and and before we go into
the broad q a so
if based on this discussion now that
we're thinking about this uh
different
questions that you have the project one
marker density give you that we have a
flexible solution for you what kind of
marker density are you interested for
your particular genotyping needs do you
need very low density under a thousand
are you more on that lower mid density
one to three thousand
at three to ten thousand or you or you
need higher density let's say above at
ten thousand so what is your major goal
i understand you have different goals
and that's why flexi is very important
and but we would like to get a sense for
for what your
appetite is for for genetic markers and
i'll give a few seconds before we go
into the q a section
hey thank you for participating we're
getting some a lot of you guys are
answering those questions so that that's
very nice to you to see we as a
community can understand each other as
well it would have been you know perfect
for could be in a room where we can
actually ask and brainstorm so
appreciate you guys
taking the time to answer the questions
here
it makes the the presentation more
interactive and i hope more and more fun
for for everybody
well i'll give a few more minutes four
seconds i should say uh until we
see if a few more folks can can
can answer here
yeah
all right so i'll push this results to
you looks like we have a good split here
between a
lower density and higher density which
is very interesting i think we we really
have a diverse
group of people attending this uh this
webinar i hope i was able to show you
some of the the capabilities and and
give you some ideas about the technology
and how we can help and i'll pass the
the question to the moderator so we can
ask some questions now
all right thank you dr nevis for your
informative presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
do you have to avoid snips adjacent to
the targets when designing probes
yeah that's a good question
there are some technologies that that's
a requirement so you need to have a snip
and then you have to have a snip free
region around the snips to be able to
target and
we do not have that constraint with the
flex seek technology we actually build
it to be tolerant
because we work with very diverse
species so yes not at all we can
accommodate the diversity that's present
on your germ plan
all right thank you
next question
what is the maximum number of markers
that can be determined using flex seek
excel without modification to the
standard protocol and what is the
highest number of markers that have been
done
yes so we we tend to operate a lot on
this
interval between
a few hundred let's say 500
and maybe 25 000 that's where we we
mostly operate for clients but we push
this
as far as
45 000
regions on the on the genome so it's
it's very flexible and and for those of
you who are interested on kits
it's the same chemistry it is a very
flexible so you can have different
pipelines run in your lab
and and your your team your
your laboratory will not have to be
changing technologies as they're going
between density and marker density
great thank you
next question
what are the best sequence and snip
analytical bio informatics tools for
flexseek are they in-house and custom
pipelines specifically for sequence
alignment management and snip calling
yes we that's a good question we the
data is very clean because they the data
starts and ends at the same position
so it's a very clean data set to analyze
bioinformatically
we we did build
our own pipeline for analysis but it was
using industry standard
aligners uh
industry standard snip callers
and some filters that we do so i'll be
more than happy to take that offline and
discuss in more details but it it's it's
no different than what other
technologies are using for a
bioinformatics for snip calling from
from naturation sequencing data
all right
next question
which sequencing platform do you use
yes so we we use uh mostly the illumina
platform that's the and and within the
illumina
sequencers
we can use the any one of them so we can
use the my seats the the nova seek the
next seat and the question will be a lot
what density do you need
what regions do you need how long do you
need the haplotypes to be if you're
going after those so there's a but it's
it's aluminum-based but it it could work
on other platforms as well
all right
next question
how does flex seek design of primers
avoid non-specific targets when working
with pseudogenes or polyploid species
yeah yeah so so my background is in my
my phd i work a lot with pine
genomes and then with sugar cane as well
so that's sort of like the my my basic
scientific career and pine is a 22 giga
base genome and sugar cane is from
octopoid to the deca polite it varies a
lot so we spent a lot of time er
adjusting the probe design
in the probe sequences the composition
of that probe that's a lot of the
intellectual property to be able to
tolerate those
complexities
the
typically that means because we we have
some flexibility as far as where we're
designing the probes we're looking for
the best genomic context that avoids
some of those challenges uh
the pseudo genes or or
in the polyploidy we're really just
looking at regions that that we can
identify
there's enough
homologous differences but we can still
design probes so that's a lot of the
probe design pipeline that we that we
built
and i'm happy to discuss this further
when we initiate a project but it's it's
a very good question
all right
next question
does the service include dna extraction
and of which tissues or seeds
yes it does er er
the world is a big place and our
communities are very very diverse
so we we've done
a range of species you know if you think
about a typical
lunch buffet i think we've done most of
those species so from livestock and in
plants and we've done some other
difficult ones
uh it's seeds yes we can
extract dna from seeds and tissue
and we prefer tissue when we can uh but
it's definitely something that we can
work with you and we've done a variety
of dna extracts and in fact lgc is very
known for for the capabilities that we
have on the dna extraction both from an
automation and also from a chemistry and
that's what we utilize here
right great
next question
do you offer any standard marker panels
if so which ones and how many markers
and what are the markers based on
if not are there plans to offer them in
the future and how many markers would
they be and how would you design those
markers
yes so so yes the short answer is that
we do
have that's that series that i call the
industry standard series that we're
developing panels that we think are good
panels for the community but you're the
ultimate judge and so we are going to
share those panels with you and you're
going to tell us you know what we
actually need to adjust or this is good
enough and this is exactly what we
needed and we've done that for for
example
in
a cattle
and pigs
we've done for a a
mace
and sugar cane and we've done for for
coffee
and blueberry and
soy cotton and so there's a variety of
panels they're available they they range
in number of markers some of them are
more in the the 3000 but on our industry
standard series our goal is to be
developing panels that are between
15 and 25 000 regions
and then you can choose the best ones or
that one if you need but that's what
we're heading towards
great thank you
next question
what is the time frame for a typical
project that requires probe design so
from probe design to results
yeah
so
uh
the bioinformatics typically takes
you know about a week if we have the
files in the right format and and given
everything that we have as far as
interactions with you
yeah as a rule of thumb we usually say
that it takes six to eight weeks to have
a piano finalized
uh and ready to be used it doesn't mean
that it cannot be done faster
but that would depend on the
interactions between us
and how fast we we can get responses
from you but that's a you know if you
want to keep a rule of thumb
six to eight weeks to have a panel
perfectly optimized
all right
thank you
and
let's see one more question
what are your average call rates
yes they they are they're pretty high
and we we it tends to be above
95
depending on the panel
so we we have very little missing data
the the level of missing data is is on
the is below a way below one percent so
very
in a very full matrix when you think
about a genotyping matrix the flexi data
is going to be a very full matrix you're
going to have high confidence
on those calls that you're that you're
making
right
great next question
what is average what is the average
depth and cycles you go for is it paired
and or single
yes so that is a that is a good point
depends on on the
on the species polyploid species we tend
to sequence a little bit deeper as the
rule of thumb we want to see at least
if we want to have high confidence data
sets we want to see at least 10x per
haploid genome so if it's a tetraploid
we want to see about 40x if it's a
diploid at 20x it's more than enough and
that's a conservative number
and most of most times we're doing
paired end sequencing because that's the
most economical
way of doing the sequencing
all right thank you
and next question can we use flexseek in
metagenomics applications
uh that's that's a good point i i
believe
we'll have to think about the the design
of the of the of the probes
so they they actually
can encompass that diversity we do have
a lot of expertise as a company on doing
a philo genetic analysis and doing very
broad phelogeny uh data tests we do a
lot of that with our capture seek
project so it is possible we just have
to understand exactly how deep we need
to go on that diversity so we can design
the probes accordingly
all right
and we will wrap up with that final
question thank you dr nevis do you have
any final comments for our audience
um i think you know thanks for for
tuning in thanks for watching the the
webinar i look forward to working with
you on different capacities
and and if there are any questions that
were
that were asked we'll be reaching out to
you guys individually as well and and be
able to communicate more so thank you
for for joining today
well thank you again dr nevis for your
time today we would also like to thank
labyrinths and our sponsor lgc biosearch
technologies for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you